y para revista de prensa nos acompaña
nuestra periodista Marta Moya Marta
Buenos días y buen viernes para usted
Buenos días María Clara Comencemos
hablando de un tema que está haciendo la
noticia en México y es que el Washington
post acabó de publicar una nota con la
que encontraron a cinco hombres
maniatados y que fueron entregados a las
autoridades y que dicha nota asegura que
el Cartel del Golfo estaría detrás del
secuestro de los estadounidenses y
supuestamente pide perdón sí María Clara
vamos a hablar de este tema que ha
venido bueno estando las noticias en la
última semana todo empezó en la ciudad
fronteriza de Matamoros donde la semana
pasada se registró El secuestro de
cuatro estadounidenses ayer jueves
fueron encontrados cinco hombres
maniatados en un camión cerca de esa
intersección donde se había dado el
secuestro días antes se encuentran estos
cinco hombres maniatados con una nota
que presuntamente
del Cártel del Golfo que es una de las
estructuras criminales que opera en ese
territorio en esa nota habría una un
supuesto perdón y una supuesta entrega
de estos cinco criminales aunque no ha
habido confirmación de que estas
personas sean los secuestradores de los
estadounidenses de la semana pasada a
menudo sostiene esta nota del Washington
post los cárteles mexicanos dejan notas
describiendo sus acciones o culpando a
las bandas rivales incluso han entregado
a criminales que han molestado a los
funcionarios tanto mexicanos como
estadounidenses Esto bueno todo este
episodio se da en un contexto donde las
relaciones bilaterales entre México y
Estados Unidos no pasan por su mejor
momento los republicanos decían no que
quieren que la administración biden
declare a los cárteles mexicanos como
grupos terroristas Incluso el ala más
radical del partido pide una
intervención militar referente al a los
secuestrados sabemos que dos fallecieron
y ya fueron repatriados sus cuerpos en
el día de ayer jueves dos salieron con
vida uno de ellos estaba herido y ya
fueron ambos trasladados a Estados
Unidos también bueno sin duda este tema
va a poner y aumentar la tensión entre
Estados Unidos y México le propongo que
cambiemos de tema y también de
continente porque en China se consolida
de nuevo como líder al ser reelegido
para los próximos cinco años de mandato
cuéntenos Qué dice al respecto el
periódico local global Times pues María
Clara global Times que es este periódico
muy Aliado con el partido comunista un
mensaje muy escueto porque la nota No
vas a no va más allá de este solemne
titular que dice chilling Pink elegido
por unanimidad presidente de China y
presidente de la comisión militar
central de la República así tal cual
bueno y no es el único medio de hecho es
una de las grandes noticias
internacionales por eso de Guardian se
refier a esta elección como una
ratificación del mando que ha tenido que
como ya lo mencionábamos antes se
convierte en uno de los líderes
históricos de china sí y El guardián
bueno hace una nota explicando que al
final
consolida su poder y será el hombre más
poderoso en China de las últimas
generaciones la ceremonia se ha dado con
una solemnidad extrema no y
perfectamente coreografiada con
levantando ese puño derecho y con la
mano izquierda en esa Constitución con
ese sello rojo en un juramento
transmitido en todas las televisiones
estatales de China y donde el presidente
chino prometió textualmente construir un
próspero democrático civilizado
armonioso y gran país socialista moderno
el nombramiento se da Después de que en
Octubre ya se ratificará
el partido comunista chino y presidente
del ejército dice el que lo de hoy es
una adición al control férreo de sí
sobre el poder pese al nombramiento pues
eh tendrá que hacer frente a una china
un poco compleja no con una
desaceleración económica con un sector
inmobiliario en problemas con una tasa
de natalidad en declive y además con
esas relaciones bilaterales con Estados
Unidos complicadas y teniendo que hacer
equilibrios con otro de sus socios que
es Rusia bueno y precisamente para
enfrentar todos esos problemas
ya determinó Quién es su núcleo de
confianza y el New York Times publica
los nombres de estas personas Quiénes
son sí María Clara son cinco personas
cinco hombres concretamente aliados y
fieles de gymping que van a formar parte
de ese núcleo duro no el primero es que
va a ser Primer Ministro va a ser liquid
que ya fue en octubre nombrado como
número dos en esa jerarquía del partido
comunista en la segunda persona que es
el Vice Primer Ministro ejecutivo
que ya fue jefe de gabinete de schin
Bing y se encargará de los asuntos de la
economía diaria el tercer la tercera
persona de este núcleo duro será
daulegie que se encargará de hacer leyes
y podrá y tendrá el poder de enmendar la
Constitución la cuarta persona será el
jefe del órgano consultivo político que
será One que bueno se encargará de ese
poder hablando y de movilizar a la gente
para que se sume a las filas del partido
comunista y él la quinta persona será el
zar económico yely feng que bueno
ayudará a reactivar esa economía China y
Ya empezaron a llegar las felicitaciones
por la reelección Sí y destacamos la de
un socio a veces controvertido que es
Vladimir Putin que le ha dicho a través
de un mensaje que ha publicado el
kremlin querido amigo acepte sinceras
felicitaciones con motivo de su
reelección Rusia valora su contribución
personal hacia el fortalecimiento de Los
lazos con Rusia y terminemos en Ucrania
porque fue el funeral de uno de los
héroes de guerra más recordados sí está
siendo hoy el funeral Próximamente Ya lo
vamos a registrar en los informativos
con la corresponsal Catalina Gómez y
hablamos de dintrococia bulane Es un
poco difícil el nombre que fue
considerado uno de los héroes más
jóvenes de Ucrania en 2021 recibió esta
distinción y así lo recordaba también el
presidente bolodimir zelemsky falleció
hace unos días en bueno en la lucha por
bahmud en el donbash y también es una
muestra de cómo al final Ucrania también
se está dejando grandes bajas en el
frente en esa resistencia en bahamut
Gracias por todo este repaso a la prensa
internacional Gracias madre claro